it was 1991 and just one day the first
chapter of game of thrones came to me
the scene where they find the direwolf
pups in the in the summer snows that
scene came to me and i wrote it in like
three days
it just poured out of me i knew they
were the summer snows so this was a
place where it snowed even in summer so
what could result that
you know wheels started turning how
would what kind of world would have that
where these people live
i've known writers who have tried to
write for the audience or for publishers
or for trends and consider just writing
the kind of stories they really want to
write the stories that that excite them
that interest them the stories that they
lose themselves in if any writer is
going to write about war then i want him
to treat war honestly so it irritates me
when i when i
i'm watching a movie
and or reading a book and
the hero
is
going through incredible dangers him and
his six buddies
and none of them die you know valor
magoolis all men must die
i think it's part of life and and art
needs to reflect life
i think another thing i noticed is um
you find just one thing that a character
loves or they hold dear and then you
find the most brutal way to rip it away
from them
do i do that i don't know
no i think you
you know you you have to take your
characters and you
have to put them through crises
that's what
that's what fiction and and drama is all
about is it's not uh you know your your
hero has a really good time uh but uh
um
things have to happen that cause the
characters to to question who they are
and what their place in the world is and
what the meaning of it all is
to to go through the dark nights of the
soul and and times of
fear and terror and
all of this
you know i've always taken as my mantra
the william faulkner's words in his
nobel prize acceptance speech where he
said
the human heart and conflict with itself
is the only thing worth writing about
um
i think that's true of all fiction of
literary fiction such as faulkner root
but also of science fiction and fantasy
and historical novels and
uh nurse novels and
whatever i mean if you have if you have
real characters
grappling with real problems the human
heart and conflict with itself doesn't
matter if it's in a castle or a
spaceship or whatever
if you have that then then you have
power
and if you don't then you don't and and
jamie
losing a hand losing the the very thing
that he defined himself on is is uh
crucial to uh i i think uh where i want
to go with the character and he
questions what do you what do you make
of yourself after you've lost that and
of course i have tyrion now going
through similar things i mean he's
always focused on the things that he uh
he did not have like his father's
respect or admiration or you know
perhaps
women didn't look on him the way he
would have liked them to look on him and
all of that stuff
but in the aftermath of the events of
the recent books
he's now realizing the things that he
did have that he's now lost like the
lannister name
and a vast fortune in gold that could
allow him to to buy and sell anything
yeah i just have to echo what everyone
else says here i mean you ultimately you
write for yourself
i've known writers who have tried to
write
for the audience or for publishers or
for trends and i've seen them spend
years and decades running from one trend
to another to try to be successful oh so
you know i'll write some science fiction
and i'll write some cyberpunks i replace
very hopper oh now i'll write steampunk
because everybody likes steampunk oh
wait a minute epic fantasy is catching
on right there don't know urban fantasy
and they keep switching genres trying to
hook on to something instead of just
writing the kind of stories they really
want to write the stories that uh
that excite them that interest them the
stories that they lose themselves in
and
you know pat was right about obsessions
too i mean
for me one of the things about the
middle ages that i love is heraldry and
there's a lot of stuff in my book about
all the heraldry of the various houses
and uh
i love it i devote a lot of time to it
um i also devote a lot of time to to
feast for some reason i i seem to have
a certain attraction to food i'm not
noticed and and some of my readers uh
don't like that they know it's
gratuitous uh
eating gratuitous eating
it doesn't advance the plot to know
how well the swan was cooked
and
why do we know all this heraldry uh it's
too much i'm not interested in heraldry
and uh
you know well fine write your own book
leave out the herald i don't care
this is my book i'm gonna put in the
heraldry
and we're not even going to get into the
whole question of sex and uh gratuitous
sex and
can any sex really be gratuitous i don't
i don't think so but no you write the
things that uh that interest you uh you
know um you used someone who was really
interested in plate tectonics i don't
think i'd be lined up to buy that bad
fantasy about uh a lot about plate
tectonics but if that's what you know
floats his boat hey
maybe he'll make me interested in it do
you like killing your characters
no i don't
why do you do it so much george
i do think it needs to be done
big fan of death up there okay um
you know valor magoolus all men must die
um i think it's part of life and and art
needs to reflect life
um
[Applause]
particularly if you're if you're writing
a fantasy novel an epic fantasy no
certainly since the days of tolkien uh
so many fantasy novels
have been about war
if any writer is going to write about
war then i want him to treat war
honestly
and
one thing i i know about war from people
who
served in vietnam and and served in
other wars is you know it does bring out
the beast in men
and anybody can die
uh it doesn't matter if you're the hero
i think everybody who died in
any war thought they were a hero right
to the moment that the bullet blew off
the top of their skull
um
[Music]
so it irritates me when i when i
i'm watching a movie
and or reading a book and
the hero
is
going through incredible dangers him and
his six buddies and none of them die you
know maybe one of them gets wounded at
some point
uh but they they will survive
pretty much untouched at the end
i mean and tolkien uh
which i read when i was young and and at
a pretty
formative age i think that book had an
immense influence on me and it does have
some powerful deaths in it my god i
really don't know what's going to happen
in this book anyone can die and it
became so much more exciting at that
point because anyone could die that
peril was real and that's the feeling i
want my readers to have that
if you're going on our
is the feeling you want your raiders to
have
yes actually
in a word if you're going to write about
fearful situations i want
you to have fear and the right kind of
fear do you remember what the original
seed of the idea was
it was 1991
i was actually writing another novel i
was writing a science fiction novel that
i've been intending to write for some
time and just one day the first chapter
of game of thrones came to me the scene
where they find the direwolf pups in the
in the summer snows that was the first
scene that you wrote that was the first
scene that i wrote yet that scene came
to me and i wrote it in like three days
it just poured out of me what about it
struck you
it was a scene that haunted me the
characters seemed so real
i knew right from the beginning i mean
that first sentence they find that there
will flips in the summer snows
i knew they were the summer snows so
this was a place where it snowed even in
summer so what could result that you
know wheels started turning how would
what kind of world would have that where
these people live what is the rest of
the kingdom like and the the world
building grew parallel to the story you
know i'm i'm writing a story and
someone makes a reference to some king
who's been dead 100 years
and i threw a few of those in and then i
said i better write a list of all these
kings or i'm going to start
contradicting myself so i wrote a list
of the targaryen kings and the names of
their reigns at some point i said i
better have a map so i sat down on a
drew map all while i was still writing
the story there is a lot of description
of the saloon inside of the steamboat or
the way to live on the boat
well it's you know
helps the period come alive
my goal as a writer is always
to immerse my readers in in the scenes
that they're writing about to make them
feel
almost as if they were living those
scenes rather than there other than just
reading about them
so i i tend to uh you know the old
writers maxim show don't tell i i want
to show i want to put my reader in there
i want them
to taste the food and see the sights the
protagonists are seeing and hear the
words that they're
that they're doing and
i can't say i always succeed in that but
that's certainly
my goal
in the vast majority of things that i
write i think it'd be fair to say based
on what you just said that you don't
write to a plan the writing more just
you know grabs you and and you just sort
of chase it
uh yes and no i i mean i i do know
where i'm going i i
know where the story ends i know the
fate of the principal characters no i'm
not going to tell any of you
um but there is a considerable amount
that you discover in the process of
writing
um that's the fun of writing actually
i've talked about uh in in many other
interviews about the two kinds of
writers the the gardener and the
architect you know the the architect uh
is like an architect planning a building
when he plans a novel he knows how many
stories is going to be and how many
windows it's going to have and how it's
going to be heated and what the roof is
made of and where the plugs are going to
be in each wall and etc etc and he works
all of that out and blueprints all of
that or outlines it in the case of a
novel before he drives the first nail or
writes the first sentence
the gardener digs a hole and throws in a
seed and sort of
waters it with his blood and hopes that
uh something interesting comes out now
you know mind you the gardener knows
certain things the gardener knows
whether he plant planted a a potato or
germanium
but
and it would be very surprising if you
plant a potato and a germanium comes up
but
a lot is discovered in the in the
process i i think all writers are some
combination of these two but they they
tend according to your personality to
one side or another and i'm much more on
the gardener's side i'm you know i think
like 90 percent gardener as was somebody
like j.r tolkien who uh you know one of
my literary idols who uh started out
writing lord of the rings as a sequel to
the hobbit and
it grew considerably the tale grew in
the telling as he said as mine has and
we want to know if you have
any tips on how
to
write better dialogue and if you have
like some authors that are favorites
um we just dialogue yeah writing
dialogue is something that hollywood
really helped me with
you know when you when you write a
script uh it has a different format it's
easily researched if any of you are
interested just by
any good reference book on screenwriting
and you'll see the uh the format and
the dialog is presented in blocks with
much narrower margins and
an experienced screenwriter as i
discovered when i went to hollywood in
in 85 and 86 to work on twilight zone
they don't even read the dialogue they
just look through and if they see large
blocks of dialogue someone giving a long
speech
they know it's not going to work
this is not shakespeare where we want
characters delivering soliloquies for
two pages they want to see short
dialogue a line or two back and forth
back and forth back and forth and that's
the kind of dialogue that tends to work
the other key to dialogue is uh
reading it aloud so like i'm about to
give a reading i'll be doing that here
when you read your work aloud you you
hear
the speeches that work the speeches that
don't work you can get a good feeling
for that so
something sometimes looks good on a page
but you actually try to deliver the line
and it
it stumbles it's because your work is so
complex and intricate both of you that i
you know uh wondered how it could ever
be adapted in other media i'm wondering
if there are things you wish that they
had been able to include that they
didn't or they're things you
particularly like on the other hand
about the way it's been adapted
um
yes i mean
for the most part game of thrones is a
magnificent adaptation of a song of ice
and fire
but
just the nature of transiting from one
medium to another
things have to be cut out i mean
we have 10 episode seasons for
everything we've done so far that's 10
hours
you look at my book so you can't get
everything in in 10 hours if you if you
tried to do it literally and included
every line of dialogue and every
character
you'd be talking 30 hours a season now
that being said i would have liked and
i've said right from the beginning that
i would have liked a few more hours
per season um some of the other hb
hbo shows that went before us like the
sopranos and the dead wood they had 13
episode seasons so they had three more
hours if we had just three more hours a
season we could have included some of
the material that was cut
particularly some of the smaller
character scenes that i think would have
deepened and enriching the experience
but our show was simply too big it was
already one of the most expensive things
hbo did it was very complex
it's it's not a show like the sopranos
that you
shoot entirely in northern new jersey um
we we have five
crews on some cases that are shooting in
in belfast and northern ireland in
morocco in croatia in spain in iceland
[Music]
it's a huge undertaking and david
benioff and dan weiss
the showrunners and the guy who who did
most of the work of translating from one
meeting another said to me at a certain
point when we were debating this george
if we had if we had 13 episodes per
season it would kill us
and i like david dan and i don't want
them to die so uh
i stopped saying that we needed 13 but
13 episodes per season would have been
would have been good
you're always going to lose things um
in that process
even
i mean my novels are gigantic but even a
novel that it's not gigantic
it's hard to get all of it into a movie
or even a tv show
uh i had before i'd made the deal with
hbo i had offers from people who wanted
to sort of success and broader the rings
with peter jackson and wanted to make
mine into a feature film and i had
meetings with them but i just sort of
laughed noticed there's no way you get
all of my stuff into two and a half
hours
um
so
i'm very glad we chose the path we did
and yes it had to be hbo you can't put
this on cbs uh you know
people people would die
[Music]
you know they would see a booby and
[Laughter]
so uh no no it has to be
[Applause]
i think it's different for every writer
i mean
the one thing that's
common for fiction writers and i know in
a crowd this size there are probably a
good number of you who are aspiring
writers or people who
who do write and think about writing
someday
it's it's not a career for anyone who
needs or values security
it's a career for
gamblers because
you know you're every time you write a
book you're you're throwing a dice again
and you don't know whether uh it's going
to crash and burn or whether it's going
to be a big success most books of course
are somewhere in between
um it's a career of ups and downs and
i've been very fortunate i've
experienced
far more ups than i have downs but i
have had a few downs and
you know dark times where i thought my
career was over and i wasn't sure i was
ever gonna
sell another book
what's important to me looking back on
those is that even at the times where
i was afraid i wasn't ever gonna sell
another book i never doubted that i
would write another book
and that's the real
thing that i think distinguishes a real
writer
from uh from the false ones that even if
you can't sell the books
you're going to write them anyway
because you've got these stories inside
you that you want to tell you have these
stories inside you that that have got to
get out and you got to get them down on
paper and
you know hopefully you do hopefully you
persist
but
it's a tough gig were there were there
things that you learned when you were
writing you know serial television that
would inform your books later on
uh yeah certainly i mean
one of the the structure of uh song of
ice and fire with his viewpoint things
and
and
cutting between the viewpoints and all
of them ending um essentially with i
don't know cliff hangers or interesting
points is is a structure i learned in
television uh you won't see it in my
earlier novels
but of course working for network
television you have to have act breaks
and depending on the structure show is
it a four four rack show is it 4x plus a
teaser or
5x uh or is it
a teaser and a tag you know what have
you but
you always have to go out on an act
break before you go to the commercial
and it can be a cliffhanger that's a
good act break it doesn't have to be it
can be just a a twist point or a new
revelation or a piece of information or
um you know something is resolved but
you know it's it's if you watch law and
order it's always
moments you know where right before the
commercial
oh my god something has changed here um
and uh the idea is to bring you back
after the commercial of course but it's
a good way to end a chapter or or an act
and sometimes it's pretty hard when
you're designing your story to come up
with those act breaks but uh you know
that's why you get the big books and it
certainly works uh
in the books too i mean uh it's
keeps people reading you know they reach
the end of the chapter and and they want
to know what happens
to that character because they're
engrossed in tyrion but gosh there's not
another tyrion chapter for a while yet
first they have to redisar your chapter
or this jon snow chapter before they
finally get back to tyrion and those end
and by the time they finish the arya
chapter there's a kind of an act break
there too and that hopefully draws them
back for the next one so yes
you